this video was made possible by hover
get 10 off your custom domain or email
from hover
at hover.com wendover when nuclear bombs
obliterate the earth or a virus wipes
out the human race or robots push
mankind
out of existence the us government
believes that democracy
should continue on the country believes
that even if the population of the u.s
ceases to exist the country should go on
akin to its almost paranoid nature the
us government
has a series of defined protocols on how
to continue the country
when the country is no longer the
continuity of government plans
you probably already know about part of
these plans because you probably know
about the u.s president's
line of succession if the president dies
there's a list of 17 people
ranging all the way from the vice
president down to the secretary of
homeland security who would take
their place with such a long list the
chances of the us
going without a president are near none
the one time a year when the entire line
gathers together
the state of the union one individual in
the line of succession
is appointed designated survivor to wait
out in a bunker
to run the government if the rest of it
dies but the line of succession
is the basic stuff the stuff people
already know
what's far less known is the semi-secret
protocols and places the government has
spent
billions of dollars and decades building
however
until just 60 or 70 years ago the u.s
felt it was untouchable at no time in
history had an enemy existed as
relatively close to the us as during the
cold war
the us's foreign policy always kept in
mind that an
ocean separated it from its enemies but
with the invention of nuclear bombs
an enemy could go from declaring war on
the us to toppling its government
in a matter of hours during these days
the u.s government began actively
preparing
for doomsday there are four main bunkers
from which the us government would run
the country
following a world ending event the
presidential emergency operations center
raven rock mountain complex mount
weather emergency operations center
and the cheyenne mountain complex the
president
is the most important person to survive
doomsday both for symbolic
and logistical reasons if a nuclear
warhead is inbound to washington
he or she would most likely evacuate
downstairs from the white house
into their underground bunker but that's
not guaranteed
during the truman administration the
president refused to leave the oval
office
during what was believed to be an attack
this ended up being a false alarm
but some presidents have said that they
believe that they should ride out an
attack with the rest of the population
it's just like saying a captain should
go down with their ship
the oval office and even the white house
bunker is not the safest place someone
can be
during an attack but morale saves lives
and
seeing a president braving out the fight
can help create a sense of national
unity
that would keep the country together a
single person
is replaceable but the government as a
whole is more delicate
raven rock pennsylvania would serve as
the underground pentagon
all the leaders of the armed forces
would evacuate by helicopter to
this facility in the event of an attack
and command their troops across
the country and the world during an
attack of an apocalyptic scale
it's likely that martial law would be
imposed meaning that the military would
take
over day-to-day control of the country
the commanders would have
wide-ranging almost dictatorial powers
and habeas corpus would be revoked
from distributing food to serving as law
enforcement to keeping the lights on
the armed forces would truly work on the
front lines of rebuilding a destroyed
country
the cheyenne mountain complex just out
of colorado springs colorado would serve
as the home to norad
the agency responsible for controlling
and tracking the skies above the u.s and
canada
so if the above-ground world proved too
dangerous for the country's leadership
these four underground bunkers would
serve as the home to the bare bones of
the u.s government
but what about the rest of it nearly 4.5
million people are employed by the u.s
federal government and they all work to
keep it running
where would the hundreds of government
agencies go
well nobody knows exactly at least
publicly
but we do know how they would relocate
you might have heard of the defcon
system it makes frequent appearances in
movies
but few have heard of cog con cog con is
a readiness level system
that directs agencies how to prepare for
the activation of the government's
continuity of government plans
at cog con 4 the lowest level every us
government
agency must be able to relocate to an
alternate facility and perform
basic functions within 12 hours it's an
incredibly ambitious plan
at cod con 3 this number goes down to 8
hours then a cog con
2 is when things get real at this level
doomsday is imminent
every agency has three sites for their
continuity plan
a b and c and their agency would split
into three
corresponding teams a b and c
the a team would relocate to a secure
facility near its normal headquarters
probably bunkers under dc the b team
would relocate
near the mount weather facility and the
c team would relocate to another
undisclosed facility each team would be
ready to take over operations at a
moment's notice
the a team would continue operations for
as long as possible
either until they're dead or
communications are cut off then the b
team would seamlessly take over
operations if the b team falls
the sea team would serve as the final
chance for the survival of the
government
agency when the surface of the earth is
unsurvivable
there is one other place to go other
than underground
to the sky the traditional air force one
has redundancy
upon redundancy and most likely dozens
of classified defense measures
but there's a different plane from which
the president might command the country
after doomsday the boeing e4 advanced
airborne command post
it became increasingly clear to
leadership under the carter
administration that the bunkers would do
little to protect against a direct
nuclear strike
in fact they would just concentrate the
very individuals that the enemy would
attack
into a few holes in mountains surviving
a nuclear
blast while seven miles above earth
however is far
more conceivable this plane is sometimes
referred to as
air force one when it matters whenever
the president travels
one of these planes is stationed at most
a couple hundred miles away
from this plane the president can
command the country indefinitely
it can be refueled mid-air by tanker so
barring technical issues it can remain
flying for as long as the food and water
lasts in a doomsday scenario this plane
could literally stay airborne for weeks
at a time
to keep the country's leadership safe
after armageddon
the united states goal would be to
rebuild the ailing country
with however many survivors remained but
how would the country continue as the
same country when most everyone was dead
because of the line of succession the
president could be an
unknown unelected official with a
bare-bones government of just a few
thousand people
so what's to say to a survivor in texas
or oregon or alaska
that it's still the same country
continuing on
well what binds america together is a
common culture and legacy
art and historical artifacts are the
physical representations of this
and their survival would pose a powerful
message
about the state of the union on doomsday
resources would be scarce
and disjointed so officials have had to
make decisions about which items to save
and which would be left behind for
example priority would be given to
leonardo da vinci's geneva davinci
over rajir vender white in saint george
and the dragon
and the declaration of independence
would be saved before the constitution
ideally though all three of the nation's
most important documents
the declaration of independence the
constitution and the bill of rights
would be evacuated from washington
grouped together they would be called
freedom documents group one and while
some high level officials would evacuate
washington by road
these three documents would get their
own helicopter straight to mount weather
to continue the powerful legacy
of the united states nobody knows
exactly how or if the u.s government
will survive doomsday all we know are
some of the plans
plans are just plans though and do not
account for the unknown
in the event that the united states is
truly threatened by nuclear war
pandemic or any other world ending event
who knows if the population will even
believe that they are still in the
united states
little distinguishes one country from
another other than what people
think and if people believe they are
part of the country of alaska or the
kingdom of california
then for the most part they are if the
principles of separation of power
judicial review checks and balances
limited government
federalism and popular sovereignty live
on past the end
the continuity of government plans have
succeeded even if the members of
government
die these plans are not about saving the
president or the secretary of defense or
any one person they're about making sure
the structure of democratic government
continues on through thick and thin
this video was made possible by hover
hover is simply the easiest and best way
to buy your custom domain or email
they have over 400 domain extensions
that let you set up
unique urls like mine
wendover.productions
you can also set up a professional
custom email in
seconds here real time you can see
exactly how long it took me to set up an
email forward
on my hover dashboard everything just
works
fast and well with hover but if you do
have a problem or
question they have top-notch customer
service by
actual human beings you can get 10
off hovers already low prices by going
to hover.com
wendover there are few things as
professional as a custom
unique domain or email so i highly
recommend checking out how you can use
one for your personal or business use
once again go to hover.com wendover to
tell hover i sent you
and you'll get 10 off aside from that
please be sure to check out my podcast
showmakers and subscribe to this channel
to get all my future videos
right when they come out thanks again
for watching and i'll see you in two
weeks for another wendover productions
video
you